Expande y simplifica 7x más 10 al cuadrado
¿Ok? Déjame hacer primero algo que está
mal. La primera tentación para elevar esto al cuadrado es decir que es igual a 7x al cuadrado
más 10 al cuadrado ¿Sí? Pero esto de aquí está mal. Lo voy a poner con mayúsculas y lo voy a subrayar,
y de hecho lo voy a poner que está súper mal ¿Vale?
Súper mal y bueno a lo mejor te puedes estar confundiendo por que sí se vale en multiplicación
7x por 10 al cuadrado si es igual a 7x al cuadrado por 10 al cuadrado
pero, es por que aquí estamos multiplicando.
Si estamos sumando esto no se puede hacer, esto está mal
y para ver que está mal pues, tenemos que hacerlo correctamente.
Bueno entonces vamos a hacerlo correctamente.
Elevar un número al cuadrado simplemente es multiplicarlo por sí mismo
entonces, 7x más 10 al cuadrado es 7x más 10
multiplicado con 7x más 10
entonces, nos queda la multiplicación de 2 binomios, así que podemos resolverla de varias formas,
como utilizando FOIL o la propiedad
distributiva pero, me gustaría pensar este problema como un problema un poco más general.
El problema de elevar un binomio al cuadrado.
Entonces vamos a hacerlo así y luego aplicamos lo que encontremos para este problema ¿Va?
Entonces lo que me interesa es encontrar cuánto es "a" más "b", "a" más "b" elevado al cuadrado. Ya vimos que no es
"a" cuadrada más "b" cuadrada ¿Sale? Entonces lo escribimos como lo que sí es, "a" más "b" por "a" mas "b" , "a" más "b"
y para realizar esta operación vamos a utilizar la propiedad
distributiva. Lo que voy a hacer primero es
distribuir este "a" más "b" en cada uno de estos 2 términos, en este de acá y en este de acá.
Entonces nos queda igual "a" por "a" más "b"
más "b" por "a" más "b"
y ahora distribuir está "a" en estos 2 y esta "b" en estos dos y nos queda
"a" cuadrada "a" por "a" es "a" cuadrada más ab
ab más "b" por "a" es ba pero es lo mismo que ab, podemos cambiar el orden de los factores,
más "b" por "b" que es "b" cuadrada.
Simplificando nos queda "a" cuadrada tenemos 2 veces ab, 2 veces ab y finalmente hay que sumar "b"
cuadrada ¿Muy bien? Entonces observa el patrón, para elevar un binomio al cuadrado,
hay que poner el primer término al cuadrado
sumar 2 veces el producto de ambos términos y sumar el segundo término al
cuadrado ¿Muy bien? Vámonos a este problema.
Ahora sí ¿Cómo le tendríamos que hacer para elevar al cuadrado 7x más 10? A pues
"a" es 7x, "b" es 10 y entonces nos quedaría, nos quedaría igual a, ahora si
el primero al cuadrado, 7x al cuadrado más 2 veces el primero que es 7x por el segundo
más el segundo al cuadrado.
10 al cuadrado, al cuadrado ¿Sale?
Ok entonces ve la diferencia
de la respuesta correcta con la que dijimos que está súper mal,
es que además del 7x al cuadrado y el 10 al cuadrado
tiene este término de aquí en medio, que se te puede estar escapando o bueno,
que se te escapa, cuando lo haces así.
Entonces hay que tener en cuenta ese término de en medio
que sale de hacer todas las multiplicaciones ¿Vale?
Bueno déjame simplificar ya nada más para ver qué nos queda, esto es igual a
7x al cuadrado pues 7 al cuadrado es 49
nos queda 49x cuadrada, por "x" al cuadrado es "x" cuadrada más 2 por 7 es 14 por 10 es 140
entonces sería 140 por "x".
Y finalmente tenemos que sumar este término 10 al cuadrado que es
100 ¿Ok? Entonces la respuesta de elevar
7x más 10 al cuadrado
es 49x cuadrada más 140x más 100.